結婚しなくちゃとか 子供作らなくちゃとか
そういう風に自分を守るための物質作っていっちゃうんです
で それ返って相手を倒すためにまたありとあらゆる武器を作ったりするんですね
それはもう人間の世界
それは今だけじゃないんで
この科学万能という時代は
これはいつでも生命が現れたら科学万能の時代なんです
だからこの古代文明なんかいろいろあるでしょ
今はもうおとぎ話ばかりになってますけど
すごく優れていたんだとかね
宇宙船まであったんじゃないかとか
そういう全然科学的な証明はないんだけど
やっぱりいくらかはそういう話を
神々の指紋とか何とか
日本語で読んだことはないんだけどね
そういうのはまあだから科学万能の時代っていうのは今だけということではならない
我々ただ高慢自大ってるだけであって
インドの古い伝説の中でもやっぱり飛行機があったりとかね
そういう話は結構あるんです
そういうこと まあなんでそんなにこの仏教で語ってはいけないと言ってる世間話を私は
仏教で禁じている話なんでずっと喋ったな
人に言うな そんな話 お釈迦様も
まあやっぱりお釈迦様もいろいろもう伝説と神話とか
そういう話の history の中に
うまくその殻の中に入れちゃって
自分やっぱり世間のことを
それで自分お考えになったこととわかったことはやっぱり言っておいているんですから
すごい工夫だなと思いますね
あれは この まあお釈迦様
昔初めてこの 目がある人は見なさいというふうな言葉でね
耳ある人は聞きなさいという感じで説法を始めたんだから
まあ発見できるものいるならば発見してみろっていう感じで
あっちこっちあっちこっち
もうなぞなぞで埋め埋めてるんです
そういうお釈迦様普段喋らない話は
でも世の中のあることだから
今 人によります コーサラ王様がある意味お釈迦様のところに行って
お釈迦様に直接質問がありますけど
何ですか？この神々っているんですかね？と言って
本当に 王様がそう言ったっていうことは
お釈迦様も結構この そういう神々がいるよという話で話してなかったということでもあります
お釈迦様はこう答えるので
世の中ではね そういう考え方もあるみたいねという答えなんですね
世の中ではまあそういう考え方もあるみたいね
そうしたら 何ではっきり言わないんですか？と
神々はいるんですか？と言っちゃったら
いるならばいると いないならばいないとはっきりとおっしゃってくださいと
それはお釈迦様のお友達でもあった仏教の信者さんでも
すごい仲良いいいものだからね
そういう話はできたんだけど
他の人言っちゃったらどうなるかわかりませんだけど
何ではっきり言わないのかといったら
コーサラ王様はね ちょっとでも頭の人であるならば
からかっちゃうんですね
ちょっとでも頭の理解できる人であるならば
世の中にそういう考え方あるなって言われたら否定してないとわかるでしょうと
かえって逆に言うんですね
それは否定していないことだとわかるでしょうと
で 何でお釈迦様は神々がいるんだという一方的なこと言わないかと言ったら
それはすごい智慧のこと世界なんです
ただいきなり何も無責任で神々がいるよと言っちゃったら
人間固定観念で先入観で持ってる神の概念にそれ入れ替えちゃって
お釈迦様おっしゃったんではないか
だから我々はありとあらゆる儀式やらあーだこうだとかね
やって神にお願いして神に作ってもらいましょうという
この恐ろしいことになってしまっちゃうんです
だからといって超次元的な生命ないということでもやっぱりないし
普段に神を見る論理っていうのを成立したんですか？神に神に見る論理っていうのはある
成立した  どういうことかわからないです
一つの学説みたいに考えられたことがあったんですか
神を見る論理っていうのが一つの学説みたいに考えられた時代もあったんですか
いいでしょうね やっぱりみんな別に証拠なしに神を信じてたでしょ
神はいる まず決めて それでどうやっているかと説明してあげようと
最初に仮説を立てて それに対して論理を行うと
仮説じゃないんだよ 神の場合は
神がいることは真実ですと
ですから 証拠はあってもなくても神はいるんだと
たまに本当にいるかと疑う人にとっては
こういうことでいるんじゃないかというふうに
いい加減な説明をする時代だけじゃないですね
仮説を立てて成立するのは科学的なやり方
それは仏教でやっていることで
だから仏教ではもうそういうもうアートマンですか
魂と神とか そういうものはもう捨てちゃうんですね
ゴミだと だからキリスト教の神学ってそれは同じことでしょ
神学っていうものがありますから
神様は実際するんだっていうことをいかに証明できるかと
科学やら論理学やら いろんなもう数学やらいろんなものを使って神を証明しようとする
あれは全くもう無茶苦茶無知なハッタリだけなんですね
神はいます それは真実ですとまず決める
真実決めちゃったら放っておけばそれで終わりですから
なんで説明するんですかね
それバカバカらしいですね
なんで証明するんですか
初めから決まってるんだから
ですから そんなもう話にならない
もう話なんです インドでも同じパターンではあったんですからね
ですから  神がいるとまず決めて決めつけて
だから神を証明する論理は全部曖昧で
例えば私は 1ヶ月間シヴァ神にお祈りしたと子供を授けてちょうだいとお嫁さんに 1ヶ月お祈りしたところで
やっぱり子供を授けてくれるかだからもうやっぱりいるんだというふうに決めちゃうんです
そういう簡単単純なこと
それで神がいると決めたわけじゃないんだから決められませんし
ですから キリスト教の世界でもちょっとしたちっぽけなことでいいんです
神がいるということは信じるために
例えば車が事故を起こして崖に落ちたと
でも自分がちょっとした怪我で命は助かった
絶対的に神を信じるんです
その場から どれぐらい崖に落ちたのに
自分が命を助けられたんだと
やっぱり神がいる そういうくだらない微かなことでも絶対にいるんだと
何かあればそれだけで十分なんですね
逆に考えない 神がいて助けたならば
車が崖に落ちたのは神の原因ではないかと
飛行機が事故を起こしちゃって
もう 300人死んだところで一人が救われた
だから神の子やと だから 300人殺したのも神ですからね
ですから証拠にならないんです
ある人が神にお祈りしたことでがんが治りましたと
やっぱり神に力がありますよと
言いならば 大勢の人はがんに死んでしまっちゃいますから
神に力がないんだと と
その分は考えないんですね
1万人がんに死ぬ時は
一人がもうずっとお祈りして断食してがんを治してくれるし
そこで神は信じるんだから
そのこと自体神はないということ
証拠なんです だから神は絶対存在しないよという証拠は
みんな神が存在するということに使っている
だからどうしても仏教ではもう話にならない
もう予知の話でもないんですから
もう置いておいて ちゃんと科学的なものごとを別に考えましょうと
全く別な枠で きっかいないですけど
おっしゃる通りに何とかそういう話はありましたね
昔は ちゃんとした学説では何でもないんだけどね
どこで話を逸れていっちゃったか忘れちゃった
まあまあ そういうことで
まあ巨大なスケールで考える
例えば生命が無数にいるならば
心は無数に無数にあります
宇宙は無制限であるならば
そこには生命があります
確かに で 最初の物質さえも
やっぱり心のエネルギーで生まれちゃうんです
最初っていうのは 今の宇宙を見て最初
その時も あの 今我々が考えている
ある一個生まれてそれからということではね
ドンともう大きなスケールで生まれるんです
それ１日 １日で生まれるわけでもないんだよ
じわじわじわじわと だから１日２日で天と地が作ったわけじゃないんです
じわじわと宇宙が現れてくるんです
そこで全ての心のエネルギーは働きかけてるんです
それで我々は今心を持ってるんです
ものを作る心 でも 全体
生命全体の心と自分一個の心と考えちゃうと
これはもう話にならないでしょう
海の力と水一滴の力っていうのはもう話にならないんですね
海はもう じゃあ暴れ回ってやろうと思っちゃったら
もうものすごい損するんですね
でも その場合も水一滴一滴がその損をしているんです
海が暴れ回っちゃって
もう陸に上がったならば
もうどうすることもできないでしょ
人間には 全部破壊しちゃうんです
でも 破壊したっていうのは
やっぱり水一滴一滴がそれを破壊したことになるんです
だからといって 水一滴にあんたこれちょっと破壊してくれませんかと
壊してくれません できない
でも壊せる力はあるんです
そこで我々にものを作れる力があるんです
そのある分は作ってるんです
それ以上できない どれくらい弱いというと
例えば自分がこう血を出すと
あの血管がもう あの 何て言いますか
硬くなること 何て言いますか
硬くなってくるんだよ
コレステロール溜まっちゃう
それ溶かしてやればいいでしょ
自分の心で そこまでエネルギーないんです
そこまでもないんです
あるならばもう別に薬飲まなくたって
自分の何か血管がちょっと硬くなってるんだと
じゃあ溶かしてやろう
いい意味で溶かすやりますよ
でも 私たちも今持っている心ぐらいのエネルギーでは
まあそれは不可能な話なんです
そういうふうなことで
この宇宙は心に作られたというならば
もう別に僕は反対してない
その心に神というならば
別に私は反対はしない
それは私でもお釈迦様ではなくて
で でもそれはある一個の生命やと言ったら嘘を言うなと
それはみんなですよ みんなで言ったって我々人間だけではないんです
この地球にいるアリから微生物から
それみんなだけでもないんです
すべての宇宙の生命が物質を作ったんです
だからヒンドゥー教でこのサイババでも言ってる
私も神であなた方も神ですっていうのは
まあかなりあの屁理屈に合ってる話なんです
ですからまあ神というどうしても屁理屈な
もう人間考えても恥ずかしく
考えることさえ恥ずかしがらなくちゃいけない概念をどうしても使いたいと
と汚い言葉で言うならば
どうしても糞を食べたいというならばという話なんですけど
どうしても使いたいというならば
やっぱり我々みんな神であって
我々みんな全宇宙を創造しているんです
創造し変化し 破壊していってるんです
では すべての生命で一体で考えないとそれは不可能である
で 破壊すると大体我々はこの今もあるんです
その いつでもあることです
私は今言っていることもいつでも今現在見て言ってるんです
別に過去を見る能力があって
過去でうちはああだああだとかそんな話じゃないんです
いつでも現在 今の瞬間の事実的に存在しているものを見て
過去と未来を推測するだけのことなんです
それで今我々の社会を見ても
我々は何か一心同体とかさどしてるでしょ
なんかいつでもそれはあるんです
何かあったらみんな同じ意見にまとめてしまっちゃうと
例えば何か人気が出てくると
みんなもう同じ人気になるものが人気が出てきちゃうし
苛立っちゃうと もう全国みんな一斉に苛立ってしまっちゃうし
バカなことをやっちゃうと
もう全国みんな一斉にバカなことをやっちゃうし
まあその中でその流れに入らない人々もいますけど
何かあるでしょ なんか例えば日本人は国民スケールで考えたり行動したりすることがあって
地球人類は地球人類のスケールで考えたり行動したりするという波が常にある
だからそこら辺ちょっと敏感にいると結構儲かることがあるんです
例えば地球でどんな国でどこでもいいし
何か何か新しい概念なんか新しい意見とか何か生まれてくるそうになってくると
その波はずっとみんなの心に入ってるはずなんです
誰も気づかないんです
僕はそれはもう結構なまけ者だから
もうすぐ感じたらすぐこれ同様のパターン
なんとなくもうそこなりの波を打っちゃうんですね
まだ自分の心になかったような
何か新しい概念が 新しい思考法
何かどこかで生まれちゃうと
もうそれちょっと敏感
おかしいなっていうことを感じて
どこがおかしいかと考えてると
パッとその概念が自分の頭の中で生まれてきちゃうんです
それは自分でそれは組織化させてしまえば
まあやっぱり 例はいくらでも言えるんですけど
なんか自慢話になりますから言わない
みんな気づく 大体年先はわかってるんです
だから私が言ってる話では
まああと何年経った頃でしょう
理解するね このテープを聞いて聞いて
あ わかりましたと 時間かかっちゃうんです
まあその時で僕はやっぱり先読んじゃうんですね
皆様の心の波の まあこういう風な波だったら
ここら辺でこういう風になるだろうと
前もって言っちゃいますけど
あまり成果はないんですね
瞑想の時でも何かこれはどういうこと？と聞いちゃうと
僕はもう一年先のこともすぐ言っちゃうんです
これでこれでこれでこれでここですよと
それで混乱しちゃう場合ありますけど
混乱しないで言ったことをずっと覚えておけば
その順番で心は変化しているはずなんです
だから今私が言う一応論でもね
まあ今の人々は気づいてないんですかもしれませんだけど
そういう話はそれから将来は現れます
まあそこでだいたいこの心はものを作るという話になりますから
このあの一応それでも知ったってもなかなか役に立たない話なんですね
心で物質作られるんだったら
私はじゃあもっと若くなろうではないかとかね
背があまり高くない人は
じゃあもうちょっと背が伸びてもらおうではないかとか
それであればもう本当にありがたいんですけど
それは不可能であると
でも私の髪の毛は白くなるのは私の心のせいなんですけど
それだったらずっと黒い髪でまんまでいればいいのに
それはそうはならないんです
そうならないのは やっぱりまあみんなちゃんと一生いっぺんに頑張って宇宙スケールで変化させなきゃいけないんです
人間が自分の構造を変えたければ
人間みんな集めて自分の DNA スケールで変化させなくちゃいけないということなんです
ですから まあ知ったっても役に立たないんだから
お釈迦様はもうあまり言うなという話になって
言っても意味がない で
カルマのことと 今私が説明した宇宙のことを考えるなと
もうお釈迦様のストップマークつけてるんです
両方もしちゃったんだけど
お釈迦様ちゃんとも 禁止マークつけてるんです
全部こちらにもまあほとんど心のことも禁止マークつけてるし
まあ全部 まあこの 2つだけなんです
ないの これで日が暮れるみたいです
この 4つで で あの今日も余計な話は全くやめようと思っていたんだけど
どうしても約束が 人に言わない
僕は約束をどうせ破りますから
自分だけに約束するんです
今日は余計に余計な話をしないと自分に約束しましたけど
であの いくらか私はこういう話で
皆様方にはこういうことを考えてほしいんですね
あの 私たちは 私にしても
この人の宗教はもう全くもうバカにしているわけじゃないんです
その人々は自分の理解の次元で何かストーリーは作ってるんです
そのストーリーっていうのは全く根拠ないのことでもないんです
自分なりに何とか感じて
解釈を余計にしてるだけのことで
例えばこのこの神 神や神やというのも
やっぱり人間の力以外で
人間の意識以外で物事を動いているんだからなんです
すべてのものを私たち今人間として持っている意識があるんですね
何でもできない意識 それ以外なところで動いてるんです
でもそれも同じ自分の心だから
やっぱり神様というのは
まあ神様だと誤解するのは無理のない話なんです
ただそれだけですから
他宗教にはすごい親切にしなさいってお釈迦様も
まあ他の宗教に対して
いくら仏教の真理をわかってもね
他の人を蹴っ飛ばしたり
けなしたりとかね 殺したりとかするんじゃないんです
本当に親切に優しく まあ接するべきなんです
仲良く それは仏教ではもうすごい強烈にもう相手を批判するな
そうじゃなくて ちゃんとディスカッションしなさい
ということ 話し合いなさい
ということで そういうことだけなんですね
理解してほしいのは 心っていうのはまあ次元ないんだからね
ものすごく繋がっちゃうんですね
ですから このあるレベルが同じくなっちゃう
繋がっちゃう 例えば戦争とか
そういう緊急状態になってきたら
いいことを考えられないんです
そこですぐ国民は一緒になっちゃうんですね
だから心はレベル同じレベルに来たら
まあ大体何のことなく繋がってしまっちゃう
だから平和な時はなかなか平和じゃないんです
なぜかというと 平和だから
我々はそれぞれ自分なりの考え方を持ってるんですね
ですから 相手の心とは繋がれません
だから仲が悪い 例えば日本人同士でも別に今は現代あまりにも豊かだから全然もう別々でしょ
みんな別々に生活してるんです
平和なんですけど みんな核家族で核個人で生きてるんです
何が平和ですかと聞きたくなるぐらいで
兄弟も一緒に生活しないし
子供も結婚したら全く離れちゃう
親と一緒にいないし 全然一緒にいない
でもじゃあ戦争の時はどうでしたかというと
兄弟子は何関係なく お互いにみんな繋がって
まあ助け合って一生懸命
あれはこのその緊急事態だから
心に大きな高いことを考えられないんですね
言われることしか考えられない
それで心のレベルが同じくなっちゃう
同じくなっちゃったら
その同じものがササササと繋がってしまいます
本当はそこに unity が出てくるんですね
ですから 平和な戦争の時は平和がないんだけど
unity があるんですね
平和な時は戦争はないんだけど
unity がない disunity 別々に
別れてしまっちゃうということ
今我々は disunity の時代です
バラバラめちゃくちゃなんですね
みんな一人ももう話合う人はないんです
だからみんな精神的に自分のことをわかってくれる人は全然ないんで
旦那さんも自分のことわかってくれませんとか
もう悩んだりとかいっぱい悩みがあるんです
epoch of disunity and peace
だから peace and harmony でしょ
英語で言えば平和と何でしたっけ？ harmony 調和
冗談じゃない  peace and disharmony なんです
真実は  war and harmony
だけどなんで世の中の人は嘘をついているか僕はわかりません
だけど私は真実を言ってるんです
だから仏教を勉強してみてください
どれほど頭が真理に猛りますかということなんです
普通だったらみんな当たり前で peace and harmony
違うんです  peace and disunity
war and harmony なんです
ただ アメリカはなんで固まっているんですかと
ずっとソ連があった時はアメリカ
アメリカと固まっていて
ソ連が崩れていっちゃったら
どこかで戦争を占う 固まらないんですね
だからアメリカこそ世界一流の一番偉大な国であって
我々は全てを支配しなくちゃいけないと
今新しい妄想概念作って今固まろうとしているんです
そういうことなんですね
ですから 戦争なければハーモニーがないんです
アメリカはハーモニーが欲しくて
そのためには何でもやる Unity
ですか 我々もバラバラな国だから
Unityの必要性 必要性が出ているんです
これちょっとしたことで喧嘩売る国
国々あるでしょ 韓国とか中国とか中東とか
ちょっとくしゃみの声がちょっと多すぎたって
それだけでも戦争になるぐらいなんですね
この中東のアラビア アラビア系の人々っていうのは
我々はすっごく なんだこの人々
お互いに人殺しやってるなと思っちゃうでしょ
でもあっちユニティーがあるんですね
イランにしたらもうコメニですか
そういう人にとってものすごくユニティーができちゃったんだ
だからもう戦争しやすいんです
アラビア人はイスラム教ということでものすごく固まってるんです
だからもうあっちこっち人殺しっぱなし
戦争しっぱなしなんです
なんでユダヤ人がものすごい恐ろしいことをやってますけど
ユダヤ人としてユニティーがあるんだから平和がないんです
パレスチナ人はもうとにかく殺してやろうと思ってる
中国人は中国人としてユニティーがあるんだから
まあすぐもう危ないんです
バラバラな国はもうあんまり戦争に行かない
例えばインドはあんまり隣の国攻めてこいってほとんどないんです
インドはすごい 南アジアではね
ものすごい大国なんですけど
南アジアの国の連合体があるんです
そこでインドは巨大な国で
他の国 ネパールとかスリランカとか
で なかなか連合体にならないんですね
それでもやっぱりインドはやっぱりメンバー一人としてすごく謙虚で頑張っちゃうんです
私は偉大なる国だから
もうあなた方は俺が言うことを聞けってアメリカみたいなこと全然言わない
全然言わない その代わりに小さなバンガローですということも
ネパールでいうこと ブータンの国いうこと
まあそれぞれもうちゃんと平等に聞いて
その連合体を運営しているんです
だからこの このサークと言うんだけどね
その連合体のサークの場合は
会長は誰がなったって別に構いません
順番で回っていっちゃいます
ちゃんとやってるんです
その時見える現象 なんでインドがもうすっごい力持ってるのに
中国との戦争しようとすればすぐできるんです
中国なんか全然もうそういうのはすごい力持ってる
ものすごい軍事力持ってるんです
で 例えばそれほとんど知らないでしょうに
インドっていうのは自分の飛行機やらなんだかんだで自分で作るんだから
アメリカから買わないんだから
ですからあるんだけど
誰も気にしない インドの軍事力気にするのはパキスタンぐらいなんですね
だからパキスタンは戦争しやすい国で
ハーモニーがあるんだから
インドにはハーモニーがないんです
いろんな宗教 いろんな民族
いろんなことが だから喧嘩しない状態
まあお互い中には喧嘩あるんだけど
まあ喧嘩しないとか そういう世界なんですね
大体 ですから このあまり一緒に固めると
そこには平和が来て 固めてないでバラバラになっちゃうと
そこに平和が生まれる
本当に矛盾だらけの世界なんです
そこで嘘を言って言うのは
またその上 また矛盾なんですね
ピースアンドハーモニーとかハーモニーとか
だからみんな平和平和と喋るんだけど
平和ないのはみんな嘘をついてるんだから
平和のために戦争するんだから
馬鹿げた話でしょう やはりそういう世界と仏教の哲学
仏教で見てる世界っていうのはすごい違うということを見てほしい
で まあそれはまあ我々
まあ私はまあもしかすると初めて紹介するかもしれませんだけど
これは原始仏教における哲学なんです
大乗仏教ですってことはちょっと間違います
ちょっと消化しにくいかもしれません
じゃあ次の二つに行って
もう時間になりましたから
で 次に仏説生まれれるのはウトと
ウトとアハラ ウトというのは
まあなんでウトという言葉を使うかというと
ウトっていうのはこのサンスカリト語で
あの  읽을か フリクトと読むんです
R Continue なんでRと
これ母音なんです サンスクリット語では
R にティングしたら ですからすごい発音しやすいんです
フリクなんです でもこれ役に立たないんで
こういう勉強したってね
フリクっていうのはこの一番フリクと辞書を引いちゃったら出てくるのは視線ですね
識 だからなんでこの言葉を使うかということはちょっと問題なんです
識も夏冬とかね そういう言葉をフリクと呼んでフリクと読むんです
フリク で 大体この まあもしかするとこの言葉はね
まあ芸術性も守らなくちゃいけないんだから
この四季によって物事を変化しているんだから
それはまあ私たち関係ないんだからね
で そこら辺も考えて その言葉を入れたのかもしれません
で アビダンマでは現象的に言えばこの火の元素
火の元素によって物事は新しく生まれてくるんだと
火の元素 日本語の言葉は自節数なんですね
で あの まあ難しくないんです
あの 自節数と書いて この一応まあこちらでは説明ないんだけど
まあ私の個人的なアビダンマの知識で言うならば
やっぱりこの地水火風の中にやっぱり火という元素がありますね
今燃えるという そこは変化の種なんですね
それによって物事は違うものに変化していっちゃうんです
そこでフリクという言葉を使っているのは
こちらで説明ないんだけど
これただ火の元素で変化する
ただそれだけではなくて
この時間という無常の世界でこの時間がありますね
いわゆる時間というのはすごいわからない大雑把なことですけど
存在しないものですけど
そのそのものにはそのその時間経過によって変化しれちゃうんですね
その変化は火の元素がするんです
それにはそれなりの時間も必要なんです
紙 1枚変化したければ燃やした方が一番早いんですね
燃やさなくたっても変化する場合は熱のエネルギーで変化するんです
置いておいたって そこでそれなりの時間も必要ですよ
紙は灰にしたければ やっぱり 30 秒間でも火の元素は頑張らなくちゃいけない
ですから その時間の流れと火の元素の働きをまとめてウトと言うんじゃないかなと思います
米はご飯にするのはできますけど
やっぱり 40 分はかかりますね
45 分間  45 分間火の元素を与えるんです
そうすると まあご飯になる
小麦粉を練って まあ発酵させていろいろしたっても
やっぱりパンにする場合はやっぱり二十分間ぐらい
まあ二十分間のはわかりません
だけど二十分 十五分間
やっぱり非能元素を与えなくちゃいけないです
そこでイースト菌を入れたっても
非能元素がなければイースト菌は変化しません
今 科学の世界で物は変化したくなかったらどうします？冷凍しますでしょ
いわゆる非能元素の働きを抑えておくと
このあれなんていますか？ナイトジェンのリキッドナイトジェン
液体窒素 だから今私たち知ってる現象の世界では液体窒素に入れておけば
もうかなり長持ちするんだとと考えてるんですね
我々の現象の場合は 液体窒素に入れちゃえば長持ちするかもしれません
それより寒いところはあるんです
宇宙の中で その場合はどうなりますか？非能元素の働きのスピードを遅くするだけ
別に変化しないわけじゃないんです
窒素 液体窒素に入れておいたんだから
一億年でも何万 何 何億万年でも持つということはないんです
物は変化する この変化はいくらか早くするか遅くするかっていうことはできます
それでも変化する 我々が早くするのは
例えばAというものがあって
例えばAというものがあるんだ
それはどんどん変化してZというものになるんだ
そこで過程があるんですね
例えば米があって 米はAで Z
っていうのはご飯というならば
それで四十分間まあ火を与えればご飯になるんですね
で 普通我々この冷凍したり
あるいは液体窒素にしたりすると
それでも変化は起こるんですね
時間は遅いんだけど このBになって C になって D になってはいくんです
なってやがて Z になるんです
四十分になるものは百年経った時なるかもしれません
それだけのこと 変化を遅くする
いわゆる変化するために必要な非能元素がないという
ものがないということ
うつというのはそういう変化であって
この場合は物質生まれるんだと
新しいもの まあそうでしょう
粘土とかね ちゃんと練って
あのロウなんとかどうと言うんですか
あのなんか入れて燃やしちゃったら全く違うものに生まれ変わってくるんだから
陶器になって変わってきませんかね
で 私たちはいろんなこのジャガイモやらホウレンソウやら
まあ鶏肉やら魚やら米やら
本当に腐って腐るものばっかり入れちゃって
そこで体というものに持ってるでしょ？今勉強したり
脳細胞使ったりするんだけど
それ全部ジャガイモとかね
もう時間とか まあまあ二つとも悪い言葉ですけど
英語で言えば で そういうもののエネルギーなんですね
でも我々はチキン食べたんだからチキンヘッドになるわけではないでしょうに
そうじゃなくて ちゃんとした人間の細胞に
人間の体に変わっちゃうんです
新しいものが生まれるんですね
で 小さな体で生まれて
私たちは大きな体を持ってるし
１キロぐらいで生まれた我々は今はかなりの体重で
私の場合は ６０キロなんですね
この重さ どこからもらったんですかというと
やっぱり ジャガイモやら米やらそんなもんなんですね
イモとかそういうものから入れて
ですから この物質は新しいものに生まれる
で 物質 あのイト ルトという火の元素で新しいものが生まれるという
増えるという 本当は増えないんですけど
変化するだけですけど
でもカンマチッタからは増えることできるんです
物質を増やしたり減らしたりすることはできるんです
で 次にアーハラというもの
アーハラというのはこの滋養素とこの前説明しました
この交換できるエネルギー
交換というか いわゆる他のものにトランスファーできるエネルギーなんですね
そこで ある物質には他の物質に
あのトランスファーですか
伝承 え？転何でしたっけ？移転ですか？移転でいいのは置きましょう
こちらにエネルギーがあって
あるエネルギーの一部を移転できる
変換できる それ変換する
この変換した させたところで違うものになっちゃうんですね
それはアーハラなんですね
そういう ４つの原因で物質が生まれる
あまり説明とかは要りませんと思いますけどね
で 例えばなんで米 米がね
ご飯になりますか？で
やっぱり火の熱のエネルギーはちゃんと変換していっちゃいますからね
そこで米の細胞の中の構造があっちこっちあっちこっち構造を変えちゃって
米に ご飯にしちゃう そういうふうなことで
すべてのものは持ってるんです
すべての物質が滋養素を持ってるんです
だからすべての物質が他の新しい物質の
物質を生むために使えるんですね
それ今我々がやってるそういうことなんです
地球の物質を使っていろんなものを作ってるんです
新しいもの 全く新しいものを創造したことにはなりませんだけど
やっぱり地球の物質をいじっていじっていじっていろんなものを作っていて
もう自然破壊するまで
環境破壊するまでものを作っちゃう
例えばあの毒作るでしょ
あの毒 何とか兵器とかなんとか言って
で アメリカで昔いっぱい作っちゃって
今はもうどうしようもないんだと
どうすることもできないけど
今ソ連でいっぱい核兵器があって
じゃあもうどうすることもできない
そんなもので まあ地球はどうなるかわからない
戦争があってもなくても
作ったものから悪い影響を与えてくれるんだから
だからもうそういうところまで新しいものは生まれちゃうんです
それはエネルギーは変換するんだからなんです
ですから この普通のよく知ってること
このアーハラのことは
このアーハラ 滋養素という変なところにな
もう名前をつけてるんだから
なんかもうかっこよく聞こえないだけなんです
アーハラは食べ物という意味だから
科学の世界ではこのエネルギーは変換するということで
すべてエネルギーですから
そういうもので我々はいろんなものを作っている
あの時計の話になりましたが
時計を作る場合は 人間は全然新しいものは一つも作らない
地球にあるものはただある形に入れ替える
そこでそのものがある働きはする
動くという それに私たちは時計という
でも人間に心がなければ時計は生まれませんね
ですから 時計が現れた原因にはこの ４つがあるんです
だから前の質問に今答えなんですけど
やっぱり時計も人間の心の 4分の2は心で作ってるんです
もう 2つは物質なんですね
ですから 時計を創造したければカンマとチッタが必要なんですね
この場合はカンマっていうのはどれぐらい成功するかっていうことに置いておきましょう
で  1日にして時計が現れたわけじゃないんだから
長い間の失敗の結果であるし
何でもそうですから それはもうカンマと同じことで
やっただけで成功しないんだから
割り当てがありますから
そういうふうなことで
時間かけてありとあらゆる積み重ね
それから人間の考え方とかね
こうやって押し開くと希望とかそういうものがあって
で 時計は徐々に現れてくるんですね
そこでウトゥですか もういろんな法則使わなくちゃ
この場合はウトゥの法則なんですね
そこでまあ時計作りまして
何かにウトゥに全部材料入れて
もうこうやってね やったってもね
まあ出てくるわけじゃないんだから
粉々にしても じゃあこれで時計ですよじゃなくて
法則があるんですね そこで法則にのっとって
それからありとあらゆる材料をまとめて
その材料をある法則によって組み立てると
それに人間の心の考え方があって
それからありと何回何回も試して試して
物は物になる それでやっと時計が現れた
でも現れて時計は終わったわけじゃないんです
さらに時計はもう進んでいっちゃうんですね
現れたものは完全じゃない
例えば昔手巻き時計あったの
これ巻き忘れちゃうと
それで時間がわからなくなっちゃう
そうすると自動巻きだったら時間が止まらないでしょう
自動巻きにする それで時計ははめ忘れちゃうと
朝起きて夜寝る時置いといて
朝起きて次の日は休みでしたから
時計はめてない 時計もう止まってるんですね
自動巻きの場合は また時間はこれめんどくさいんだと
じゃあ手で巻かなくても
自動巻きでなくても それだったら電池でいいんじゃないかと
いろいろ電気時計使ったりし
いろいろそれからどうせこの機械時計っていうのは機械だからもう正確じゃないんですね
時計は より正確に時計をどうやって作れるかどうかと
で 考えて 今は電子時計ですか
その今あるんですね あのちゃんと標準時計から自分のうち手で使ってる時計も
世界の標準時計からコントロールしてくれる時計まで発展しているんです
で 八百屋らしいで売ってるんです
まだあの腕時計までは出てきてないんですね
ありますか ですから まあもう開発はしてもう随分進んでますけど
まあ一般人には出してくれないんだからね
まあ全部軍事用ばっかりですからね
というのはもうあると思います
ですから 今私たちのその時計
私たちは手ではめていると
この世界標準時計から宇宙船じゃなくて衛星通って信号をもらって
ちゃんと秒を秒をしっかりと決めてくれる
そういうふうにまあ進んでいくんですね
それでも将来になってくる時計はめるのめんどくさいんだと
何か DNA なんとかカラクリして
自動的に人間時間知られるようになんかできないかと思うかもしれませんよ
あるいは体にあのバーコードでもつけて
いろんな建物にバーコードあって
建物に入っちゃうと 何時何分だとすぐ時間知らせてくれるとか
もうわからないです これから人間どんなことかな
そういう風に変化していくんですね
物事っていうのは ですから
全ての物事の変化っていうのは
仏教ではカンネチットウトゥアーハンという風にわかります
で 科学の世界ではウトゥとアハラだけしか考えないんだけど
科学者発って発明しているすべてのものも
やっぱりカンマとチッタがなければ生まれてこない
例えば 人間にはいいカルマがついてないと新しいものを作ることもできないんです
失敗しちゃうんです ですから
例えば科学的には豊かになっているでしょ
我々もカルマがいいんだからなんです
なんだかんだで成功するわけじゃないんで
途中で研究をやめる場合いっぱいあるんです
やめなさいと ですから
このそんなにもできないんです
ですから 人間すごく恵まれているならば
いいものはできちゃうし
恵まれてない場合は怒りやらそういうことで科学発展すると人間不幸になるものはできてきたりする
だからカンマ チッタ ウタ
アハラと 4つで 4つのエネルギーで物質は生まれるんだと
そこでウトゥとアハラというのは物質そのものなんですね
でもカンマ チッタは心ですから
それだけ区別して置きましょう
全くもいまだかつてなかったものは
初めて生み出そうとするならば
それは心にしかできない
いわゆる無の状態から
もう何か有の世界を作ろうとするならば
もう心にしかそれできない
で 仏教で無の無の状態の有のはもうものすごいエネルギー溜まってる状態ですけどね
そこら辺ちょっとはっきりしないんだけど
この我々が今考えている変化は
まあただエネルギーの変換だけなんですね
ですから エネルギーは消えませんとかね
なんとか形に変化するぞという物理学的な学説は出てくるんですけど
エネルギーは消えませんという学説はありますね
でもあれは科学者の学説で仏教の説じゃないんです
消えます エネルギーも消えるし
新しいエネルギーを作ることもできるんです
いまだかつてなかったエネルギーを作ることもできるんです
でもその作り方は知覚か風しかないんですからね
別に珍しくもないんです
そこら辺で終わらせざるを得ない状態なんですけど
一応今日の部分は大事なんです
省略はこれからはできるだけ省略します
この明るい心で頑張りなさいというのは
心が明るければどうせ常に体に物質生まれてるんで
エネルギーが 明るければずっと生まれる
このエネルギーはちょうどいい調子しているんですね
いい調子のエネルギーが生まれる
そこで注がなくちゃいけないんですね
注ぐと その に なんて言いますか
物質がいい体になってくるんですね
でも 4分の1でしょ 心のエネルギーはいくら明るくたっても
だから体の 4分の1は健康的にはなるんです
そこで でもはっきりと 4分の1じゃないんです
なぜかというと これでカンマで割り当て決めちゃいますから
例えばもう 60%成功する人の明るさの心から 60%のいい物質しか生まれてこないんですね
そこでそれでもこれ合わせちゃうと結構いいものなんですね
そこで 60%でもいい物質が生まれちゃったら
そのこの世界に入ってくるんですね
物質は物質を生み出す世界になってくるんですね
そこであと 31%ぐらいいい物質が生まれる
いわゆるいい体を持ってる
食べるものはいい結果を出しちゃうでしょ
そうすると健康的になるんです
だから仏教は全然甘い話をしませんから
まあ心さえ清らかであれば
もうがんもない もう何も病気ないとか
それは万病もなくなりえますよとは言わないんです
心が清らかになると その 4分の1は体は清らかになる
でもいつでも清らかな心で
いわゆる明るい心でいなくちゃいけない
1日 10分だけ明るくニコニコと
それずっと怒りやら苛立ちやらね
もうストレスばっかりだったらダメなんです
いつでも明るくニコニコ軽くと
そこが難しいんですね
で それでもやっぱりカルマの割り当てがありますし
それでもあれからいい物質は生まれてきてくれる
で いくらか割り当てが多くなる場合
それで体が出てくると
それからこの体 物質生まれるんだから
このそれから人は食べることを行動することからのいい体がついてくる
ですから まあ私の好き勝手な計算で言えば
明るい心でいるならば
大体6割  7割ぐらい  8割ぐらいは健康的な体を作ることはできます
残りは諦める どうせ病気にいわゆる老化しますからね
それはもう一生かけられません
遅くすることはできます
でも後でひどい目に遭うんです
なぜかというと もう体はあまり年取らないと元気で元気でいて
やっぱり死ぬ時期近づいてくると
こっちのエネルギーは消えちゃうでしょ
いきなりドーンともう全部倒れてしまっちゃうんです
例えば 80歳になっても
40代  50代ぐらい元気で元気でいて
85歳になってきて いきなりボケて年取っても何も手の足が出ないで
そうすると精神的なショックは多いかもしれません
徐々に年取っていくよりは
それはそれはどうでもいいことなんですけどね
ですから この完全に完璧に治るということは置いておいて
体はどうせ崩れていくんだから
その分は置いておいて
我々には健康に明るく幸福で生きていられるんです
その法則がわかってしまうと
心は確実に物質作る ですから
同じ海苔巻き弁当を食べても
暗い心で食べる人が病気の体作るし
明るい心で食べる人が健康な心を作るんです
ですから ただ海苔は体にいいという風に決めつけるなと
海苔は体にいいのは心は綺麗に綺麗な時だけです
だからパクパクといろんな健康食品を食べたっても
それはどこまで自分が欲がないかというところから結果が得られます
そういうことで その分は役に立つ話なんです
じゃあ今日はありがとうございました